con quale faccia possono incontrare la
mia ex ragazza dopo otto anni che non la
vedo
non posso credere che stiamo facendo
questa cosa e allora cosa è successo io
sono diventato conosciuto che io stavo
già insieme a lei perché lei è stata una
dei miei primissimi iscritti iniziato a
seguire il peggio eravamo in fretta
sentire avevo 17 anni quando ci siamo
lasciati se non c'ero rimasto male e ho
preso tutte le cose che lei mi aveva
regalato e le ho messe in un baule ok in
uno scrigno tipo skyrim che ho buttato
nel mio garage e non l'ho mai più
toccato oggi andiamo a casa mia a
prendere il paure lo portiamo da diletta
che è la mia ragazza e vediamo che cosa
c'è dentro un unboxing
siamo studenti di chris è questa nella
mia villa venite e quindi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto un triciclo
broaden di ho guidato questo fino ai 26
anni perché poi la patente o presa 26
questo quadricicli a parte sono passati
otto anni e questo è il ballo c'è un
problema io avevo chiuso con questo
lucchetto che gigantesco famiglia lo
aprono validare sera chiave sono passati
otto anni
ero incazzato si vede che ha incassato
quando ho messo a roba qua dentro parigi
[Musica]
wow
attenzione skill andiamo dalla mia ex
ragazza a portare questo ben di dio
[Musica]
vabbè ma tu stai spaccando tutto
come mio cuore
ho soltanto quando io wow ragazze lo so
mi state veramente invidiando è finito
segreto
[Musica]
la dj originals avevano detto che ti
aspettavi non lo so questo altra persona
perché devo fare io far entrare se vuoi
sarebbero 10 davanti cinque piani a
piedi non ho il maxi di rose ma ho una
minore che questo ma ti spiegherò dopo
che cos'è oddio no io penso difesa e mi
sento stravolta ma proprio tanto
ma il positivo o negativo ma lei non
siamo su di max primo fa stranissimo
cioè una smart sarà qualcosa che li
stavo dicendo prima
mammarie che strano io quando ci siamo
lasciati
come posso dire non l'avevo presa
benissimo ok quindi ho preso tutte le
cose che mi avevi regalato barra che
comunque condividevamo in qualche modo
che centrano tra mente e le ho messe
dentro questo affare non so veramente
che cosa ci possa essere dentro
sentiamoci perché serve fare un viaggio
indietro nel tempo dove anche a voi
interessa perché qui si fanno i cazzi
non sia sempre come non mi ricordo
assolutamente cosa c'è dentro tiriamo
fuori completamente a caso e commentiamo
la cosa che non sappiamo che cosa è
veramente un momento storico
io poi la cosa che c'è il centro di
camionista allora questa bellissima
felpa di assisi black flag la domanda ma
tornò sai che viaggio ho fatto per
andarsi a prendere questa felpa avevo
anche una foto che farò vedere questo
momento bellissimo componenti lorenzo
non è servita a dimostrare questo grazie
un po di carica live perché eravamo
innamorati diretta
andiamo avanti con il prossimo oggetto
quando io no bellissima di rigoni che mi
aveva insegnato farlo ma la nato l'aveva
fare lo sta provando fatto ieri da
maurizio berruti ma da due vita azioni
che separa
c'è un giorno la pesca ed abbiamo della
stu falsa perché abbiamo nella sua base
perché della sua patologia campo insieme
ai temi ma noi abbiamo finito ma ci
lasciate non abbiamo finito infatti
hanno aspetto non sa come fare il grande
tom ha vestino finiscono roulette o
quanto lo stesso guarda c'è anche
scritto si vede incanta con un realismo
profondo e penetrante ma non dovevi
farmi questa dedica non c'era bisogno a
proposito di andare nel dettaglio
e tu hai per caso visto vi ho fatto
degli dei video
ma perché non andiamo avanti con questo
video
io sono curioso posso posso essere
curioso posto per mezzo milione a lei
madre mio padre io ad un certo punto ma
andiamo avanti quest'anno boxing
no no perché poi titolo ha visto anche
la mamma no peggio però così freddi
praticamente apparsa la reaction al
video the rock
non mi saltava quindi è che se il sangue
si trova nella zona del cervello
non sta nel piano stanno e luci bravo fa
vige bravo non funzionano funzione
permesso a piangere
il giorno dopo andiamo avanti ragazzi
spezzare una lancia a dire che è stato
un bellissimo momento dettaglio siamo
andati nei forum online e forum nucleare
io facevo questa cosa quando dovevo
uscire anche quando deve uscire come si
basta l'aria giuro su dio next one
velocizziamo perché se non
c'è una c poi ci sono delle lettere che
nostro alza la voce brava allora
lenta crescita di così
io penso
come se
non penso che una trave m.na possa far
ciò che ho fatto
noi che sarà joker bui ma tu c'avevi del
chianti nel comma e rimembra ciò che ti
ho appena detto non dimenticare perché
un di vivere sotto lo stesso tetto
e poi si che lo destino faccia soccorso
ricordati sempre che io sono il puzzo
lino e tu il puzzo corso
ma secondo me questa è la lettera
d'addio sì perché mi ricordo che qua
sotto c'è altra roba bisogno di un
insieme che tu mi hai regalato una
stella di mare ma mai pensavo che un
giorno sei alberi nato qualcosa ma sta
ancora la prima è la stella col mio nome
no no
il nome della stella si dicono le cose
diletta sito il nome della stella e no
no è troppo grigio mista con coraggio lo
dice logici se hai il coraggio di ci
supera innamorati in jam ero immaginata
una casa 20 bambini però il primo
bambino si doveva chiamare rai caso con
la sera casciano studi potesse rai alla
studio e terrificante che il ryan verrà
jan scatola come nostro figlio compagna
davanti ragazzi dove con proprio un
ostello si comprano su amazon ha insomma
allora questa è la mia lavagnetta che ho
spezzato a metà perché ero incazzato
perché non si chiede perché va allora il
discorso non lo ricordo bene qua dentro
non c'entrava allora fatto
de sica stati sì ok questo se lo
ricordano anche lord ancora ma per
strappare io lo tenevo sopra nei video
dietro in alto teniamo questo qua e
l'avrei fatto tu che cosa c'è lì dentro
c'è un cd di qualcuno
[Musica]
chiamo amore mio scritto capello
risaliti facendo i video
ti facevo i video quando andavi via che
pattini magari no di camigliano chiama
my
scartano buon san valentino amore mio il
leggero anticipo bacino
carta cosa
rigorosamente comprato al cinese di
scandicci ha
non solo
perché ci sono dei condom ricomprato
tipo i mega pacchetto e mi ci sono dei
condom comunque che
questo è un libro che però non fa cose
che hai dentro io lo so perché avevo
questa voglia di fare una specie di
diario della nostra relazione
ma che bello ma cosa dici se tu avevi
fatto il fumetto nostro fini come ci sia
ancora ma su io sto male ma guarda
quanto ho fatto bene ma cos'è
incredibile
en toi perché c'è un pezzo di mutandine
va bene ma chi si stesse che stavi
piangendo mentre iscritto questo
febbraio 2015 siamo già lasciati
quest'anno ma resta quindi una maglietta
no
ci sono le tue lacrime su questa pagina
ci eravamo lasciati già da un po che
cos'era febbraio si sono lasciati anno
con me da un mesetto si dispiace che non
abbia no non lo so much non ho letto
niente è il caro libretto è da tanto che
qualcuno non scrive su di te siamo nel
2015 è passato un anno l'ultima volta
che ti abbiamo un anno due sì anche se
sembravamo una quercia questa si è
appassita la cosa bella il lato positivo
di quando un albero viene abbattuto e
che con il tempo un nuovo germoglio
fuori crescere quando saremo persone
migliori e rinate rivivremo come la
fenice che rinasce dalle proprie tribù
ma dai che tenne a dire che sappiano
dispiace per queste lacrime e le lacrime
dell'isolotto sincero va beh ma che ci
siamo diciamo non fatti male a vicenda
però abbiamo pianto entrambi molto
intenso come cosa